we all see Whiskey Pete's as we drive
between Vegas and California but as you
pass by on the 15 what you might not
know is that whiskey Pete himself may
just be watching you built in 1977
whiskey Pete still stands tall off the
I-15 Freeway Welcome to our little
Casino I'm whiskey Pete come on over
here talk to me for a minute but the
true history of the property dates back
much earlier when Pete McIntyre now
known as whiskey Pete began his mining
career some of the legends that was
around at the time our coffee shop on
the back of our menu said that he was
you know he sold gas here in the 20s and
30s that he also had a still set up and
a mine shaft somewhere nearby he would
make moonshine and you could fill up
your gas tank and buy moonshine and go
down the road when Pete died in 1933
Legend has it that he wanted to be
buried standing up with a bottle of
bootleg in his hands when I came to work
here there was always a grave marker
write you the off-ramp coming from Las
Vegas just a small stones and a actually
a wooden cross matter of fact it would
fall over once in a while I'd put it
back up his grave was then Disturbed in
the early 90s when construction on a
train began near the mile marker where
Pete McIntyre was said to be buried we
called the coroner out had them come out
check it out make sure there was no foul
player or nothing to that effect so now
whiskey P can keep a close eye on the
property and maybe a
on the hotel guests we talked about
where to put them we figured let's put
them someplace where you know he's never
going to need to be moved again I'm not
going to say where that is but he will
never need to be moved again so we made
him a new coffin We buried him upright
like the legend said and there are some
things are just unexplainable so we call
it Pete's law so there's things that go
on out here that you know you just don't
expect to happen and they do it's been
said that gas tanks have been filled up
overnight in the parking lot and that
ghostly figures have been spotted at the
front entrance I've heard I've heard
people talking about they stopped off
here because their battery died on the
on the highway they parked it and they
got a room and then on the way out the
door the battery is fine they made it
all the way Vegas no problems the gas
tanks I mean they you they will
attribute every every ounce of good luck
they've had here to Wikipedia and I I
believe he might have something to do
with some of it from the spirit of P2
being in the possession of artifacts
from two of the most notorious murderers
of all time there's a lot to experience
at the property so let's walk around
there's a lot to see in this room from a
bathtub to a bar to these really cool
artifacts what do we have on the walls
over here well these are not actual
artifacts we actually really had actual
artifacts in the room at one time but we
had customers wanting to take pieces of
History home with them so we put those
down with the cars on display the hotel
Clyde artifacts over time from different
auctions which led to the original
creation of the themed Suite it's
interesting because in the past some of
those artifacts used to be actually up
in the Bonnie and Clyde Suite but it got
kind of spooky people people were like I
don't know if I want to stay in the
suite with these artifacts in here so so
we may move them out and made them part
of the attraction over at Primm Valley
that's right the infamous death car sits
right here in Primm Nevada they were on
the wrong side of the law and the law
eventually caught up to them and the
whole story and everything's available
over there it's an amazing story well as
we sit here in the death car of Bonnie
and Clyde we're reminded of the history
and the Mystery that remains here in
Primm Nevada
[Music]
thank you
[Music]